a história e ela começou lá atrás na
minha infância quando era criança
na região de são paulo era próxima de
regiões periféricas da cidade ea minha
mãe era médico obstetra então era muito
comum as pessoas de todas as comunidades
carentes ir buscar ajuda da minha mãe na
nossa casa nós vinham das mais diversas
situações referidas doentes ea minha mãe
sempre recebeu todos de braços abertos
até a nossa casa para que pudesse cuidar
da melhor maneira que fosse possível
dentro das possibilidades dela ela
também eu a partido mas mais jovem eu
também tive a oportunidade de acompanhar
nos hospitais
a companhia ela fazendo partos normais e
cesáreas inclusive um parto dentro de
táxi tremenda loucura
isso tudo foi alimentando em mim uma
grande admiração pelo que ela fazia pela
vida das pessoas
elas fazem realmente a diferença na vida
delas
isso foi incutido dentro de mim por
muito tempo eu tentei a carreira de
medicina tentei 23 anos era um sonho da
minha mãe em um sonho meu também
acabei não conseguindo ingressar em uma
faculdade e acabou optando pela minha
segunda opção que era arquitetura
fiz a arquitetura me formei e comecei a
trabalhar no ramo da arquitetura
corporativa fazendo projetos de lei aos
escritórios
trabalhei nos últimos dez anos nos quer
dizer nos primeiros dez anos nos mais
importantes escritório de arquitetura
corporativa de são paulo projeto para
grandes corporações nacionais
internacionais
depois desse período comecei a pensar
exatamente o que eu estava fazendo com
minha arquitetura que a inspiração da
minha mãe poderia fazer com que
utilizasse isso dentro do meu trabalho e
começar a repensar sabe que estou no
caminho certo aqui no mesmo momento a
cidade de são paulo também já não me
atendia na minhas necessidades mais
básicas como qualidade de vida ou o
contato com a natureza segurança e
chegou um momento que eu decidi
de romper com tudo isso não basta não
era isso que eu queria para a minha vida
não era isso que eu queria para poder
estruturar minha família
aí conversando com a minha esposa
chegam-me decidimo vamos dar um basta
nisso vamos romper vamos sair de são
paulo filho projetamos nossa mudança
para florianópolis
florianópolis é uma cidade que a gente
sempre foi muito apaixonada
criamos bastante pra cá e sempre
sonhamos de morar aqui e eu lembro que a
gente juntou todo largou tudo que a
gente tinha casa amigos família e
emprego é a nossa segurança pessoal
largamos todos os invernos lembra que
chegamos aqui em floripa foi bem no
natal chegando aí entramos em um
apartamento vazio
estava eu e minha esposa e meu cachorro
chega num momento ele toda em piada com
a nossa mudança foi tudo que coube no
carro
juntamos todo e viemos e aí bateu uma
insegurança quando teve aquele ambiente
vazio
daí eu falei pra minha esposa e agora no
que quer fazer
largando tudo então uma situação
completamente diferente desconhecida pra
gente e ela sobra pra mim relaxa bom
aproveitar o verão eu estamos aqui numa
praia linda em um ambiente maravilhoso
tema que faz parte do nosso sonho eu
falei tá certo vamos aproveitar e
aproveitam foi ótimo mas assim que
terminou a gente foi lá e começou a
batalhar pelo nosso sonho e realizar
nosso sonho de se estabelecer por aqui
vou ter um portfólio embaixo do braço e
comecei a percorrer todas as empresas
locais mostrando a arquitetura
corporativa e todos os conselhos que eu
aprendi ao longo dos dez anos de
trabalho em são paulo
mas aí eu me deparei com uma realidade
completamente diferente aqui era um
universo menor empresas mais simples mas
com cuidado com as pessoas
incrível então eu comecei a perceber que
o bebê
o time arquitetura para esse todos os
conceitos não daria aplicar conceitos
grandes corporações um ambiente tão
diferente e teve um momento crucial foi
quando comecei a conversar com os donos
das empresas foi muito diferente de
grandes corporações que o nosso contato
para desenvolvimento de projeto é um
gerente é um diretor é um facilities uma
pessoa que está preocupada em
incumprimento mas atingiu buriti muitas
vezes somando demandas da grande
corporação que força tal situação aqui
não encontrou o dono o cara que sonhou
com este projecto o cara que sonhou com
este negócio que investir o dinheiro do
próprio bolso e que quis tornar esse
sonho uma realidade
foi aí que comecei a pensar poxa
então tenho que adaptar toda a
arquitetura para um novo normal um novo
normal você pode imaginar o mundo na
globalização que a gente tem hoje
pessoas vêm de diversos cantos e de
outras cidades largo também suas
famílias seus empregos e vão atrás de um
sonho comum dentro de alguma empresa
por exemplo aqui pessoas de diversos
cantos do país para trabalhar e eu
estava vivendo exatamente isso
pessoas que deixaram suas casas toda sua
segurança e como criar um ambiente de
trabalho para poder juntar toda essa
turma gerações diferentes culturas
diferentes expectativas diferentes como
fazer com que todo esse grupo se
converse se entenda interaja diferente
de espaços mais formais né de antigos
escritórios
a ideia sempre foi trabalhar com
ambientes muito mais abertos
participativos fazer com que as pessoas
se conheçam pessoas que vêm de fora vão
encontrar na cidade o seu ponto de
contato na empresa o seu ponto de
contato
vai ser a empresa que não formar suas
novas amizades formatar sua família
então
é um espaço sim tem que ser muito
valorizado e foi aí que ele começou a
aplicar os conceitos mais adaptados como
se fosse uma grande família com fosse um
ambiente familiar que remetesse casas
que remetessem ambientes de comunicação
praças bares e foi aí que a gente
começou a entrar com esses conceitos
espaços mais abertos para que todo mundo
possa se ver sim se ver e ser visto
a comunicação livre dentro do escritório
ambientes informais de reunião porque
não uma reunião numa sala de estar como
a poltrona de massagem ou através de
redes porque manter a característica
básica clássica de uma sala fechada
quatro paredes uma mesa no centro porque
não áreas de descanso
todas as pessoas podem dormir depois do
almoço relaxar no livro há descanso
também pode ser de reuniões áreas de
loud espaços divertidos como bar pub
espaço onde tenha cerveja mesmo disse
luca mesa de pôquer locais de
convivência só esses locais que tenta
trazer planeta dos ambientes de trabalho
e fazer com que as pessoas consigam se
comunicar e interagir e formar suas
novas famílias locais
as consequências de se aplicar ambientes
divertidos leves dessa forma é muito
clara uma redução tremenda no novo
relação a fofocas intrigas internas uma
maior sinergia entre os grupos de
trabalho
as pessoas começam a se conhecer melhor
pessoas que não tinham relacionamento na
linha de produção de uma empresa
extremos consegue ter um ponto de
contato e se conhecer melhor
são locais onde vai ter compartilhamento
de idéias
muitos locais onde vai ter também o
fortalecimento da identidade da empresa
aí são pontos onde as curvas vão se
criar as novas características empresas
fortes por isso que a gente sempre fala
assim que é
muito importante dá sempre a atenção há
estreitamento do relacionamento dentro
da empresa
as empresas hoje como roberto tinha dito
muitas vezes não é mais o nosso segundo
lá é realmente nosso primeiro a gente
passa muito mais tempo dentro da empresa
em contato com os nossos amigos do que
com nossa própria família ou com nossos
amigos pessoais
a empresa se torna realmente um grande
ponto de contato de encontro e de
desenvolvimento pessoal bem
por fim não conseguir só me tornar um
médico que a minha mãe sempre sonhou mas
não consegui através da inspiração que
ela me deu aplicar dentro da minha
captura e buscar com que isso seja um
ponto criador de bem estar e de bons
relacionamentos dentro da empresa e
dessa forma fazer a diferença
nem que seja pela mesmas oito horas
dessas pessoas mas fazer a diferença na
vida delas
então cada projeto busca inspiração da
minha mãe pra poder fomentar tudo isso e
é isso aí tentar fazer a diferença na
vida das pessoas dentro de nossa própria
profissão
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]